let's go next to how about uh Chris from
Texas Chris from Texas welcome to the
show what's on your mind today
all right can you hear me right now yes
I can
okay I have two questions I guess we're
regarding healthcare okay
my first question is regarding the like
like drug shortages that right now I'm
just wondering
why isn't like Biden been like more
restrictive on like Controlled
Substances such as like for Adderall
right now given that it's kind of
hurting a lot of people right now I
don't know that I have a specific answer
as to why he hasn't I mean I just think
it it's clearly not a priority he didn't
campaign on it he didn't pretend that
that was going to be his big Focus so I
don't I don't I know you may be looking
for a different type of answer but I
just don't think that he's made it a
priority
yeah because I mean from what I've heard
right now is he's actually restricting
the levels of it like Adderall
production right now and other control
like other c2s for like ADHD right now
and I'm not aware of what a lot of like
Biden restricting Adderall production I
haven't read about that
um for like from the D from the DEA
let's see he he's certainly working what
I'm reading is that the Biden through
the DEA are looking at limiting
prescribing but that the underlying
reason may be more limited production
but I'm not seeing that Biden is the
reason for the limited production
okay so I guess in that case I'm
probably maybe over emphasizing the
Biden with the vea in that regard yeah
could be
okay my next question is I remember
watching a video one time a long time
ago about Healthcare in the United
States and like there's a there was a
city I think in Montana Montana called
Libby
that had like some kind of Health Health
crisis that ultimately led to this to
Obama like I think around 2008 leading
to him uh giving us help giving that
that City you know Universal Health Care
so I believe it was it was asbestos
right
yeah I think so yeah
do you think it's possible I mean I mean
I mean granted the Supreme Court's
pretty much stacked right now in
conservatives favor do you think it's
possible Biden would ever be able to
Biden or another Democrat in the future
would be able to do an executive order
to try to mandate health care that would
be a great overscope of the government
to mandate it in what way
uh I guess kind of like using the same
logic that that Libby Libby Montana had
to give it it's its citizens their
health care I don't think so so here's
the thing here this is a complicated
issue because the president is the
president and is connected to the
federal government and right now we have
some federal health care programs like
for example Medicare is federal but
administered at the state level Medicaid
Medicaid I'm sorry Medicaid's the state
level one medication Medicare is the
is the federal yes it but it's still
administered at the state level so let
me see if I can let's forget everything
I was saying because we kind of got
derailed I think the point here is Joe
Biden I don't believe would be able to
mandate that states have to provide
Health Care directly like I don't think
Joe Biden would be able to say Vermont
must have single-payer health care which
Vermont was considering at one point in
time I believe that the most direct way
for a president to expand Health Care
nationally would be to lower the age at
which you can get Medicare
or to raise the income at which you can
get Medicaid although states have to
accept that those would be the most
legally simple ways for a president to
expand Access to Health Care
yeah I guess I guess you're right so but
I guess the other issue is that like for
would be like with State States like
Texas trying to sabotage a Medicaid
expansion
right that's that's the issue you can't
there were States who was part of
Obamacare just declined the Medicaid
expansion and so the question then
becomes can the president mandate that
states have to do the Medicaid expansion
I don't know it's a legal question I
just don't have the answer
yeah all right thanks for the time David
all right Chris from Texas great to hear
from you one of our sponsors today is
Bluetooth a unique online service
delivering the same active ingredients
as Viagra and Cialis in a chewable form
and at a fraction of the cost and
they're giving my audience an entire
month's supply for free so if you think
you could benefit from an extra boost of
confidence when it's time all you have
to do is take a short quiz on their
website a licensed doctor approves your
prescription the medication comes
straight to your home within days in a
discrete package no driving around to
the doctor's office or the pharmacy no
waiting around no awkward conversations
with your doctor all of Bluetooth
tablets are made in the USA the entire
process is just a few clicks go to
bluetooth.com the link is underneath
this video they'll give you an entire
month's supply for free when you use the
promo code Pacman all you have to do is
pay five dollars shipping